camp has returned if you miss
camp 2021 then fear not because
camp 2022 is on right now featuring many
of the biggest streamers you know one
notable exception has been xqc whose
last minute back out from the event
sparked an argument with her son and led
to the creation of a 30 t-shirt
commemorating what happened
so
what exactly did happen let's get into
it
hello hello did you know that september
is statistically the best month to
subscribe to the score esports yeah i'm
still working on actually proving that
but just subscribe now and we'll
figure out the details later also leave
a like if you enjoyed the video thanks
alright so the first question we have to
answer here is what is camp
as a sentence i thought i'd never say
the event was started last year by cutie
cinderella as a follow-up to shitcon
earlier in the year the events were an
excuse for some of the top streamers to
get together play some games and produce
a lot of content in the process the vibe
was kind of pub trivia night meets
freshers week but with cameras streaming
absolutely everything that kind of vibe
now both of these events were pretty
successful and up to this point there
hadn't been any similar events this year
so when qd cinderella announced the
return of camp everyone liked that
count 2022 was to feature some
familiar faces from last year's events
such as hassan casey tron myth and
ludwig as well as additions such as
zoyal valkyray and erob and this year
fans were even promised fishing and
archery yes archery i really hope that
becomes its own category on twitch that
would be dope the event started on
monday this week and viewers can watch
directly on twitch or through the
shitcamp site which also features
popular clips from any of the streamers
at the event and they even made a merch
section for all the camp super fans
but while the main event is in full
swing at the time of recording this
video we need to go back before it all
started because that is when the drama
began xqc was at last year's camp
last sunday he started streaming and it
became clear that despite him confirming
that he would be going to this year's he
wasn't going to be there after all that
is just weird man like jesus man
bro
i'm not going to the event towards
everybody everybody's so riled up like
holy man
where was all that hate and agent
involving about it but that's sort of
not going there what what like what
about the people that when last year
they didn't come this year they said
that there's no what about these guys
like where was it going nuts like
relax man
xqc had shared the full reason for his
decision in the offline tv discord he
said staying home not going soda gone
and all don't feel like it it's a lot of
people i need someone like soda to run
good stuff soda if you haven't guessed
already is soda popping another big
streamer and someone who xqc spent a lot
of time with at the previous
events now perhaps that's a fair
excuse but for some people like
camp 2022 attender hassan it came way
too late on twitter he said xqc bailing
last second on camp is obviously
bad cutie busted her ass for the event
and spent a lot of her own money to make
content for everyone i think him
claiming it's because soda's not coming
and that the event will somehow be bad
is unfathomably awful i'm sure there's
more to it and i don't want it clouding
an otherwise fun event amongst friends
just feels icky to carelessly on
something someone else worked hard on
even if you had legitimate reasons to
bail beyond wanting to do gambling
streams ultimately i was excited to see
everyone including xqc and i'm still
stoked even though it's going to be 1
billion 38 million 743
939 degrees in the sun and i'm sick hope
we don't die and naturally xqc disputed
what have been said well you join
somebody you're the opposite you start
with a rumor and you saw a dog and
you work your way downwards
and i would expect a friend especially
one that that stuff that i cannot you
know
we would that we rekindled to not work
downwards
that's dog
that is lame
bad faith actor
fake politician
tyt dog
fired employee moronic andy
i said it
okay
now some of you will already know this
isn't the first time xqc and hassan have
butted heads sometimes they're pretty
chill with each other and they have done
a lot of events together and other times
they've definitely clashed most recently
when hassan called out xqc for his
gambling streams sqc placed hassan in
the beta of his streaming rankings and
the whole thing just exploded from there
i'm sorry he's just never been a good
person to me and i don't care
oh no also asman farmed the johnny depp
schrell harder
i don't i don't like the language here i
think this is disgusting getting back to
camp though hassan jumped on stream
after his tweets to elaborate further on
his thoughts
no i mean i i don't think i said
anything up at all i i think it's
it is up
um for the most part that like xg last
second bailed out
look
there's a lot of stuff that happens
behind behind the scenes
uh that that you know you're not privy
to and i'm not privy to let's be
real now while this whole back and forth
was going on it could have been easy to
forget what exactly started this whole
thing camp now at first she
appeared to be doing a little bit of
damage control urging fans to focus more
on which streamers would be at the event
rather than the ones who'd announced
they weren't going but by the end of
monday night she basically said it
and in pretty hilarious fashion released
a 30 t-shirt commemorating those like
xqc who weren't going just like my
grandma always says if you can't beat
them meme them camp will continue
until the 8th that is tomorrow at the
time of recording i don't foresee any
more drama coming from this but who
knows i'm not going to overanalyze xqc
and hassan's relationship here but i
will say it's kind of hard to know how
real these arguments are on a deeper
level even xqc recognizes that
did he take it did he take the due
diligence of the information that he had
was wrong or true or did he double check
or reach out once they haven't no did
not he assumed the worst because he had
to gain the most and he just maximized
that that's what happened
literally
that's it
and is that somebody you want to be a a
genuine friend with over a long period
of time and make it an actual bond or is
it more an acquaintance for stream and
for content if there's one thing we all
know it's the controversy sells calling
out xqc one of twitch's biggest
streamers is guaranteed to get you
attention so it's hard to know when
someone's problem with him is really
serious and i'm not necessarily saying
that's hassan but i'd be interested to
know what do you think of the whole
situation are you enjoying camp
2022 so far thanks for watching and i'll
see you all in the next one
i think i got allergies
i feel like that's something you never
hear in the uk like the sort of like the
broad word people just said just saying
allergies like you are allergic to
something but people like people tend to
specify they'll say like if it's grass
or pollen it's like hay fever but here i
just hear people say my allergies